peut-être un tournant dans la sphère
grégory la faire de ce petit garçon noyé
il ya cinq ans dans une rivière des
vosges la vologne
ce matin le juge ciment chargé
maintenant du dossier a procédé à une
nouvelle audition de christine et jean
marie villemin les parents du petit
grégory
la mère a été inculpé en 85 s'en
souvenait d'infanticide
selon son avocat elle devrait bientôt
obtenir un non lieu à dijon
dominique verdeilhan souriante détendue
christine villemin sort en fin de
matinée du bureau du juge simon avec la
certitude que quelque chose a changé
dans le dossier grégory un 23e rendez
vous avec le magistrats dijonnais qui
laisse entrevoir un non-lieu pour
christine villemin
inculpé par le juge lambert en juillet
85 pour l'assassinât de son fils pour
nous avocat du couple et jean marie et
christine villemin
le non-lieu pour grichting cette mère
admirable est aujourd'hui une certitude
mais le combat que nous menons depuis
cinq ans continue nous voulons tous
connaître sur ce crime innommable les
assassins et leurs complices doivent
être confondu la découverte de la vérité
passe par le mobile le mobile les
assassins et leurs complices deux points
forts de l'instruction évoqué très
récemment par le juge simon lui même
christine villemin en passe d'être
innocenté les regards se tournent de
nouveau vers bernard laroche premier
inculpé de la faire après le témoignage
accablant de sa belle soeur muriel bolle
aujourd'hui le mystère grégory reste
entier on peut s'attendre dans les jours
qui viennent à d'autres auditions à
d'autres inculpations
le juge simon n'avait-il pas annoncer
lui-même de probables rebondissements